let's jump on to the phones we've got a
lot of people wanting to talk 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 is the number to call and we
will start in fact with a caller from
the 607 area code caller tell us your
name where you're calling from and
what's on your mind today
David this is Josh from from Salem Mass
great I was just up in Salem not long
ago you guys have this great new arcade
bar at an old jail which I really liked
I think it's called a bit bar which part
of Salem I don't know I'm right downtown
and yes it's called dip bar that place
is pretty awesome cool all right what's
on your mind today so as a as the
president of the Salem Mass chapter of
the fans of vegan Pat society okay we
are wondering whether in the spirit of
producer Lewis when will producer Pat
get to try his hand if he's interested
at hosting the bonus show I don't know I
don't know I mean Pat is increasingly
involved in story selection for the
bonus show but you know you've got to
remember Lewis was on the program for
years before he hosted the bonus show so
you know it's all a process and I mean
do you want to chime in on this at all
Pat well I'm not maybe one day I'll be
capable of doing such a task feeling
you're not ready a tough yeah all right
no it's a fair question it's a fair
question but I think that you know this
is there's a lot to what goes on here
and we will it once we have something to
announce we will announce that is fair
and you know no pressure we're all ready
our bodies are ready just just keep in
mind keep in mind that we'd like to see
that are you worried though that the
story selection on the bonus show would
just turn into you know Pro veganism
rants or you know talking about the many
scandals that have infiltrated the David
Pakman show over the past year well you
know we
to society think that the the scandals
have been a little overblown okay with a
fakes news yeah but wow I think all
right we'll listen I don't want we don't
want to go overboard with this but we
will consider your the comments of the
society and hope to visit Salem again
soon although not on Halloween it's nuts
I recommend not going to Salem on
Halloween